george floyd had his struggles
but he shouldn't have died that day the
prosecution told the court
the video of his arrest that shocked the
world once again shown to 12
jurors who now need to decide if this
was murder
george floyd said i can't breathe 27
times but derek chauvin kept his knee on
his neck
for nine and a half minutes the
prosecution
arguing he did this on purpose telling
the jury
believe your eyes what you saw you saw
only you have the power
to convict the defendant of these crimes
and in so doing and in so doing
declare that this use of force
was unreasonable it was excessive
it was grossly disproportionate it is
not an excuse
for the shocking abuse that you saw with
your own eyes
and you can believe your own eyes
this case is exactly what you thought
when you saw it
first it's what you now know in your
heart
this wasn't policing this was murder
the prosecution reminded the jury
officer after
officer had testified this was an
inappropriate use of force
he knew better he just didn't do better
said the prosecutor the defense
said otherwise derek chauvin removing
his face mask
as his lawyer reminded the jury any
reasonable doubt
should be a ruling of not guilty
the defense showed extensive body cam
video of derek chauvin on the scene
arguing george floyd resisted arrest and
posed a threat to officers
that many factors killed him including
drugs and a heart condition
they even argued bystanders distracted
derek chauvin
at the moment george floyd took his last
breath
and that the former officer was just
doing his job
officer chauvin had no intent to
purposefully
use or he did not purposefully use
unlawful force
it's it's these are officers doing their
job
in a highly stressful situation
according to their training according to
the policies of the minneapolis police
department
and it is
it's it's tragic
america is tense in the knowledge an
acquittal
could see an explosion of unrest around
the country
as the world watches we wait
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis